in order to guide or direct you must
have a certain level of control of
anything di speaking out for the first
time since those controversial comments
he made about his daughter
Noah we had a conversation we have
yearly trips to the gynecologist to
check her hi hey that was TI earlier
this month on the ladies like us podcast
talking about his 18 year old daughter
deja I'm being criticized because I'm
willing to go above and beyond to
protect my now the rapper and his wife
tiny are clearing the air on read table
talk with Jada pinkett-smith yes indeed
yeah tip and tiny and of course he's
going to address the controversy that
has been swirling and then he and tiny
sit down and talk about how they
survived in regards to their marriage in
part one of the two-part special TI
admits he now sees why everyone was up
in arms over the admissions he made and
the sensitivity surrounding what he said
I didn't get it I was oblivious to it
however I am now sensitive to it for her
the rapper also reveals deja asked him
not to speak on the subject after he
began receiving major backlash taking
the bullet last night I don't have a
problem with that
until I had different directives okay go
ahead make it stop clear it up you know
understand and I would not be here today
had I not had those different directors
I'd still be sitting in silence although
the 39 year old rapper says he has
learned his lesson when it comes to
talking about his 18 year old daughters
personal life he doesn't see anything
wrong with being protective for there to
be malice there must be ill intent
mm-hmm if I'm going to the doctor with
you just for the sake of controlling you
then okay but if I'm going for the
purpose of being a protective parent and
there's nothing there's no such as
overprotective that's protected and
particularly since Dasia turned 18 TI
says he's no longer in control maturity
before going into certain things but it
was never about well the Virginia's not
protected I'm not there to protect
necessarily virginity I just know that
is a big move right now once you make
that move okay there we go
things that happen that follow right you
have to be equipped GI says he just
wants to protect Asia from players keep
your expectations low you can't get your
feelers wrapped up in this now this is
this is a physical earth animalistic
urge is taking over right here this is
not an emotional romantic encounter for
this gentleman don't think it is GI and
tiny have always been protective when it
comes to their six kids here's what they
told et in 2013 when you have six kids
you you have to take you know have some
family time so you can just get all your
time in with all the kids show everybody
their attention and you know I think I
catch them in what they're doing see if
you add them later you just let them you
know run off in tension and they'll
never have to come back but you could
look them in the eyes and smelly fingers
person fingers me oh really yes you can
okay would you spell it for moms read
the destination neither here nor there
yeah sweet sweet
[Music]